uh with us now is the former Chief of
the general staff uh Lord Donna hello to
you Lord thank you for joining us on the
program this morning what does this
actually mean for Finland
well for Finland it means that they
joined that really important Club the
North Atlantic Treaty Organization and
are covered by Article 5 of the North
Atlantic Treaty which means that an
attack on one country's attack on all
members and now Finland is covered by
that protection which as your
correspondent has just said given that
finland's got an 810 mile border with
Russia it's a that's a pretty massive
future investment in their own security
was of course
um ruled by Russia until its
independence uh just over a century ago
they are on the border still with Russia
though aren't they and I suppose my
question is could there be some tension
between Finland and Russia as a result
well most definitely there can be
tensions between
um and you're right that Russia has
previously ruled Finland but um if one
thinks back to the winter of 1939 1940
the Finns and the Russians caught a very
bloody war with each other and to
everyone's surprise uh Finland held off
the Russian mic for quite some time to
finland's disappointment countries like
Britain and France which might have
otherwise have come to their age that
didn't and actually that was one of the
factors why Hitler thought well if
they're not going to help the Finns I
don't think um they'll bother bother me
if I if I push in Europe so there's
quite a history between the Russian and
the Finnish relationship and um yes
there will be tensions and of course
their tensions Will Rise
um
unsurprisingly but importantly when uh
at some point in the future other NATO
countries make deterrent deployments on
Finnish territory along the Russian
border because uh Finland although it's
got nearly an a million Reserve forces
only has about 25
000 active Armed Forces
um so they were very much appreciate and
enjoy and need uh deterrent support from
other NATO members which leaves me leads
me and nicely to my next question my
Lord which is what does Finland bring to
Nato
well it brings it brings a lot of I
think moral support is probably the
right answer
um I mean Finland has for a long time
God is very jealously it's it's
neutrality but it's felt for its own
reasons that it now wants to come under
the NATO umbrella and that's fair enough
your question is what does it bring to
the rest of NATO in physical and
Military and Hardware terms at this
stage not a lot but I think uh Finland
will need some encouraging to invest
further in its own armed forces and that
will bolster the overall capability of
NATO but yes the implication behind your
question is is fair we have now taken on
additional liability for an additional
810 miles of Frontier with Russia but I
believe many people believe it's the
right thing to do the Finns think it's
the right thing to do
um and uh personally I'm pleased it has
now happened and hopefully Sweden will
be able to join soon
is it more power to the Elbow of
somebody like Putin though who has said
see I told you that NATO were trying to
encroach uh closer and closer to the
territory that is Russia and we need to
defend ourselves from this NATO alliance
yes but it also encourages or it
underlines the need for Western
politicians to stress again and again
NATO is purely an only a defensive
Alliance we have no offensive thoughts
as far as Russia is concerned that was
the case throughout the Cold War uh with
NATO against the Soviet Union and Warsaw
Pact we were purely defensive we remain
purely defensive
um yes Putin may walk try and play it to
his people people that this is NATO
expanding and technically that is
correct but why is it expanding because
there is a growing concern amongst
countries like Finland and Sweden that
Russia represents a threat to them and
it's therefore not unreasonable that
those two countries are seeking the
overall protection of the NATO umbrella
so it's really important that Western
leaders NATO secretary generals
um Western presidents Prime Ministers
and so on keeps stressing this point
that NATO is purely a defensive Alliance
it would be remiss of me my Lord to let
you go without asking you about the east
of turkey
suggestions that it's now under Russian
control uh we were told that it was very
symbolic for Ukraine to keep it where
are you on that
well in many ways has already served its
purpose as far as Ukraine is concerned
uh the Wagner group wanted back in
September October last year to claim a
success that the Russian army was not
able to Claim by capturing Bachman it's
taken on six or seven months of very
bloody fighting to do it fighting which
has cost the Russians on a ratio of
about one to six one to seven more
Russian fatalities than it has Ukrainian
fatalities so Blackwood has been a bit
like they're done in the first world war
it's to a major extent bled the Russian
forces
blood than white which of course is what
the Germans were trying to do to the
French in burden back in 1915 1916.
um so if the Russians have managed to
make further moves into Blackwood and I
don't think they've captured the whole
of the place yet then um as I say it'll
have been a peric victory of some
hollowness for the Russians to have
gained more control over backward I
don't think they've gained complete
control and frankly if I was the
Ukrainian commander-in-chief now I think
I'd withdraw the rest of my forces on
the basis that bakumud has done its job
for Ukraine how interesting um it's
always a pleasure to see you my lord we
miss you in the studio come and see us
soon thank you yep I'm okay thanks thank
you